[Music]
contact poy it's one of the most
visually impressive forms of Po spinning
and manipulation out there but where to
begin with it Drex here from Drex Factor
po sharing with you the love of Po
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
take you through what I think are the
first five tricks that you ought to
learn when getting into contact po but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys jug GL
calling pyrot Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca beonin thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so
contact PO is kind of a weird outlier in
the world of Po in that it's not reliant
on a lot of the techniques that are
required for learning a lot of
traditional po spinning and this is
something that can both work for as well
as against us because it doesn't require
us to know all of those fundamental
principles but it does require us to
learn a whole bunch of brand new ones
that have nothing to do with the first
set so with that in mind if you're
interested in learning contact po I have
five tricks that I think you ought to
start your journey with that I think are
going to set you up for Success down the
road and we're going to go ahead and
start that Journey off
with trick number one the
Cradle okay okay so this isn't
technically a trick in and of itself but
it is a technique that pretty much
everything else on this list and that
you will ever learn in the contact poy
world is going to either benefit from or
absolutely require a lot of contact
petrics require us to find ways of
balancing that ball-shaped head and our
natural inclination is to grab at it the
problem being that this is actually
counterproductive to maintaining
stability in this position so one of
those first hurdles that we have to get
over in learning how to do contact PO is
learning how to catch the ball by
extending our fingers rather than
clutching them together you can begin to
practice this technique by extending
your fingers as far as they'll go and
then bending them back upwards away from
your palm from here you want to balance
the ball on top of your hand and work to
try and extend your fingers further
every time you feel the ball becoming
unstable walk around like this and even
give yourself some shocks to either side
and see if you can train yourself to
create that Bowl rather than creating a
fist now fair warning this is going to
take a little bit of time for you to
learn because you're basically rewiring
a bunch of reflexes in your brain but
the good news is that it helps set you
up for Success down the road including
my next pick trick number two inner
forearm
rolls all right so we're finally rolling
the POI along our body and I'm giving
you what is probably the most intuitive
way to do this the setup for this is
pretty simple you just spin the tether
backwards as you're holding the head of
the POI and then you simply release the
head if you've done this right and lined
up the tether properly you'll wind up
with the tether finding its way back to
your hand right about the time that the
head rolls off at the end of your elbow
hopefully allowing you to make a perfect
catch I mean describe like that it
sounds simple enough so it's the big
deal right well there happen to be two
things about this that you're going to
need to learn that are going to be true
of pretty much every other contact role
that you ever learn the first of these
techniques is figuring out how to line
up the tether as it spins before you
initiate the contact roll as it turns
out every single contact roll requires
the tether to give it momentum and
Direction therefore you don't want to
start this roll with the tether just
spinning parallel to your forearm you
want to actually have it at a slight
angle that way it's guided to the
outside of your elbow rather than
straight back into the middle of it in
addition there's another reflex you're
going to have to train yourself out of
every time we feel something falling or
Rolling Along one of the surfaces of our
body body we want to create a ramp for
it unfortunately this also makes the
roll more unstable you want to keep the
surface that the PO is rolling across as
flat as possible again this is going to
take a little bit of practice to get
down cool so if you've got down the
basics of knowing how to do the Cradle
as well as knowing how not to create a
ramp with your forearm then you're ready
for my next pick trick number three the
outer forearm Roll All right so this
without a doubt is the classic contact
po roll that most people associate with
the genre it was first invented by Rona
mlin more than a decade ago and it is
still a classic to initiate this move
we're going to start in the cradle that
is you're going to have the tether
dropping between your index and middle
fingers and the head balanced on the top
of your hand from here you're going to
swing the tether back and forth like a
pendulum until you feel it tap against
the edge of the bone in your elbow from
here you're going to give your wrist a
very very small flick and let the ball
roll all the way along your fore arm
until it gets to the end of your elbow
if you've lined up the roll properly you
should find that the handle winds up
back in your hand right as the head is
falling off the end of the elbow again
things to watch out for you want to
avoid having your forearm go up and
create a ramp you're going to lose
control of the ball if that happens and
also to you're probably going to want to
come at this from an angle that you have
your forearm in front of you as though
you're trying to block a karate chop I
know a lot of people that first learned
how to do this roll kind of off on a
diagonal and when it came time to chain
that roll together with other moves they
had to relearn how to do it of course my
favorite presentation for this roll is
to start it from a throw namely an
isolated throw in which you fling the
handle around forwards and then catch
the head on the back of your hand from
here you can just simply do a quick
flick with your wrist and continue on
the contact roll once you catch the
tether huh you can do the whole thing
again marvelous okay so thus far we've
covered a lot of the basics as well as
how to do do inner forearm rolls and
outer forearm rolls now we're going to
start getting into some more nuanced
stuff that's going to set you up for
some of my favorite tricks down the road
starting with trick number four reverse
outer forearm roll so yeah on the
surface of it this one doesn't look that
much different from the trick that we
just learned but it does have some
really specific elements that I think
are important to get down sooner rather
than later this trick is almost the evil
doppelganger of the trick that we just
learned rather than starting from a c
and initiating a ro from there we're
trying to get to a cradle doing this
involves taking the PO with one hand and
wrapping it around the elbow of the
opposite hand from here we flick the
tether and we initiate a roll all the
way down to Landing in cradle from here
we have the option to reverse the roll
back with that outer forearm roll that
we just learned in our last section and
completing two rolls in one now granted
it's rare that I see people performing
this role anymore and I think that's
kind of a shame
not only does it teach you some
interesting things about how to continue
momentum that starts from one place and
ends in another but also too it is a
really good stepping stone for getting
towards things that involve more
compound paths we have to think of
momentum in a different way with this
role rather than getting to start the
momentum from the hand that is connected
to the forearm that the PO happens to be
rolling across we're now initiating it
from elsewhere and just continuing that
momentum we have to do a little bit of
adjustment here in order to keep the PO
rolling in along the line that we want
it to be this is going to be really
important for things like folding lines
down the road so before I share with you
my final pick for the five contact pyric
that you should start with I do have a
favor to ask if you come this far I'm
guessing that means that you have an
interest in petrix and maybe in learning
Po in general and I have great news for
you I produce lots of videos on POI and
flow arts in general so if you want to
check out more of those videos the best
way to do it is to subscribe to the
channel not only does that mean that you
are the first to know every time I drop
a new video but it also helps my videos
find a new audience please go ahead and
sign to subscribe soon or rden later
thank you in advance so now my final
pick for which contact poy trick you
should start with is Trick number five
the inner forearm Catch and Release so
straight up this trick absolutely
baffled me when I first saw people
performing it there was something about
the catch of the tether and having it
wrapped around your forearm that just
did did not compute for me now I've got
a better understanding that what's
really happening here is we've lined up
the tether in such a way that it winds
up wrapped around the forearm as we
reach up to catch it now this also
becomes a great way to reverse the role
just like we saw in our last example too
this is also kind of cool because it's
one of those rare examples in contact
poy where we actually wind up with a
suspension that is we can pause the
movement of the POI for a second and
strike a pose if we'd like to there uh
it's also a great way just to like halt
the PO for a second as you're in the
middle of a combo say you want to really
really emphasize the thing that's going
to come next so you use a little bit of
Stillness to build the tension and even
better when you get this down you can
put it together with that outer forearm
roll that we talked about in our last
section and produce the folding line
which is without a doubt my favorite
contact po trick both of these tricks
are absolutely essential for getting
this one down so what did you think of
my list are there contact poy tricks
that you would put on your list that I
didn't put on mine leave me a comment
and let me know what they would be and
if you'd like to get full tutorials on
most of the tricks on this list plus a
few others I did a series of contact
Point tutorials a few years ago that was
sponsored by Ultra poy I will go ahead
and leave a link to that playlist down
in the description as well as up in the
cards please check it out if you're
interested in learning
[Music]
more
this video would not be possible were it
not for my awesome supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
for supporting my channel and my mission
and if you out there watching are
enjoying my videos and you'd like to see
me make more of them there's a great way
that you can help out and that is to
head over to patreon and sign up over at
patreon.com drexfactor po not only are
there a lot of Awesome rewards available
over there but also too that will make
it possible for me to devote more time
to creating videos rather than having to
teach private lessons or other things to
bring money in that take me away from
producing videos so if you want to see
more of these that's the way to do it
and if you want the inside scoop on even
more crowd-pleasing poy tricks you
should check out my top five poy tricks
with wow factor I'll go ahead and
include a link to that down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourselves today and
I'll see with a new video real soon take
care now peace